Lauren Southern is an author and a
filmmaker and some of her views are
considered offensive by the neoliberals
in charge of everything for example she
thinks unrestricted illegal immigration
probably not that good for your country
and because of that big Tech has decided
to make it impossible for her to live in
the west Airbnb has refused to allow her
to stay in any of its properties without
explaining why by the way if you have a
vote felony record you could probably
stay at an Airbnb but now Airbnb has
decided
to take a close look at Lauren
Southern's family because her parents
are related to her by Blood
the genetics are incriminating and her
parents are no longer allowed to stay at
Airbnb a common practice in North Korea
so we reached out to Airbnb and its head
of public policy former Obama official
Jay Carney an Airbnb claimed this was
just a mistake but of course it wasn't a
mistake because they explained that they
were doing it because these people were
close to Warren Southern in their email
this is the company by the way that
banned January 6 defendants
or in southern remains banned by Airbnb
she joins us tonight Lauren thanks so
much for coming on
um so I mean what kind of world is it
where not just the thought criminal but
the thought criminals family is banned
from spending the night what is that
there's definitely been a Pandora's Box
opened in the culture War I think
progressives have realized with the laws
we have in place defending civil
liberties they can't quite bring a
social credit system in yet so they
found a way to circumvent it through the
corporate class they can just impose a
social credit system on us using big
Tech
do you think your parents will be
allowed to buy food or receive Medical
Care since you're against illegal
immigration
in the next few years who knows honestly
this is escalating at such a rate I
never could have expected of course
Airbnb have reversed their decision for
now uh claiming they are very sorry but
I think we both know the only thing
they're sorry for is bad PR in that they
were trending on Twitter last night
well I mean and they admitted it in in
their communication to your parents they
said your connection to Lauren Southern
makes you ineligible so I wonder if you
were like a convicted
Armed robber would they do this to your
parents of course they would not even
consider it right
they don't even treat the families of
Epstein and Maxwell like this right and
what was funny is when they reversed the
decision they claimed in an email to my
parents that they had reviewed their
appeal my parents never appealed the
decision so they're attempting to create
this phony narrative that it was all a
mistake how do you mistakenly track down
an activist's family mistakenly send
them a specific email saying it is
because of their relation to me it makes
no sense they're trying to cover up
something nefarious here and the only
reason they aren't continuing to do this
to me is because I have a platform and
they're testing the waters if they got
away with it this time they would have
kept going but they miscalculated how
woke their Market is
this shouldn't surprise us these are the
same people who Who attack entire groups
of people on the basis of their genetics
some groups are innocent some are guilty
I mean it's it's classic Nazi race
science you're implicated by your blood
I mean that's what Airbnb is saying
essentially yes and I gotta say
disappointing things for me is that it
has gotten to this point that we've
spent so many years having Republicans
defend cronyism by pretending it is
capitalism and then our Fail-Safe which
was supposed to be progressives who are
supposed to question the big
corporations when they are
discriminatory specifically on blood and
genetics uh they're like an ADHD dog
that just got distracted by a bone with
a pride flag on it and placated entirely
so we're left with just activists on
Twitter thank goodness your show you're
really holding down the fort for
conservatives who want to have their
freedoms but
it's it's just a real shame
well yeah I mean what's it's not hard
you shouldn't punish people's parents
For Thought crimes I mean it's like yeah
that seems an easy one Lauren Southern
great to see you tonight thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight